if it was sucking a little harder you
would be like oh that kind of hurt
that's what she said today we are going
to try this new vacuum that's gonna suck
out of our pores it looks like it could
be a sex toy okay I'm getting like
vibrator vibes I don't know if this will
work well this even work I really hope
gross stuff comes out I really want to
see what lurks underneath in order to
get the most out of my face I'm gonna
open up my pores with this hot towel Oh
Oh God I'm giving myself hickey it's
guys that's we have a lot of suction
power for something this small but you
can really really feel it tugging at
your skin and hopefully getting some
stuff maybe some dry skin some oil maybe
like a nickel or a dime in there too I
don't know how hard the slow process the
thing is like do it work on my skin I
don't know with it this is a good thing
or a bad thing I don't see anything yet
oh yeah you know there's little streaky
marks but not at you now I'm looking at
it so there's at least a ring of oil
around here which I'm happy with there's
a solid ring of like just I don't even
want to know what that is little pieces
of me which is disgusting but also kind
of satisfying it's just Ruska that's
visually saying how much is in your face
you can see some my poor juices in here
so I think that's pretty cool I'm
permanently blushing on this side of my
face so I can't recommend it it seems to
get some stuff like off my skin so it
definitely worked I think my face feels
very well circulated right now like a
blood pumpin
[Music]